none of us disappeared we all made it
look at that just like has that face of
just like oh yeah he's a villain how do
you respond to mind over muscles like
this the MCU who's the strongest
Aventure who's your favorite villain
we're taking those questions on the
[Music]
street Captain Marvel I got to go with
Thor Iron Man Hulk Captain America w ooh
good call I mean she can use her powers
for good or for evil just watch One
Division manipulated a whole town does
Ant-Man count yeah a small But Mighty
I'm going to go with that yeah but he
can turn really big too exactly Thanos I
is he an Avenger he was the hero we
needed but we didn't deserve Thanos was
when he did the snap you approve
absolutely I approve too of what Thanos
did when he like Snapped the half of the
Universe I
agree is Spider-Man an adventure yeah
that counts Spider-Man is technically an
Avenger by the end he has my favorite
character definitely I'm going to have
to go with Carol danverse she kind of is
like the break glass in case of
emergency for the rest of the team
exactly I know a lot of people want to
say Captain Marvel but just my gut says
it's still the Hulk because I just keep
going back to that scene in the first
Avengers movie with him and
Loki go with Thor okay so you think your
boy can take down Hulk huh yeah yeah
Mind Over
muscles how do you respond to mind over
muscles like this I mean I also think
you have to ask you know who's the most
emotionally strong Thor is probably a
little more emotionally stronger than
the Hulk is lot a lot of things to take
into consideration with that question
strongest Avenger access denied probably
Iron Man even though he is a little bit
of like a douchebag but you know he has
a heart a fake heart but a heart so you
think he wins against Hulk yeah they
have different powers Iron Man can fly
yeah what does the hul do sit there and
just pounce ugly
[Music]
basically I'm going to go with Thanos I
mean you know Thanos is probably the
most popular one sure he has like the
really fancy glove it's very high
fashion it's called a gauntlet so the
gauntlet it's very fashion forward
that's why he's my favorite if it's not
Thanos who is it I have to say please
don't say Iron Man you almost read my
okay okay no no trolling uh I just want
peace I love Loki a lot you think he's
good sometimes but you know that there's
that tricker underneath I think he's the
most human of them all I feel like we
can relate to him he's deep there's lots
of layers to lowy outside of just your
typical evilness it's like a seven layer
burrito where you can't trust any of the
layers right yeah maybe like that one
layer is probably good but the rest
going to make you regret the morning
yeah surprise Ultron I think he was
super menacing is definitely a little
scary like the suit of armor around the
world and stuff like that AI gun Rogue
I'm so I'm like with that big Spider-Man
fan so I will have to say Green Goblin
he's officially a part of the MCU now
yeah I mean it's bringing back an OG
Spidey baddy and it's still Willam Defoe
and he still got Willam defo face just
like has that face of just like oh yeah
he's a villain he's like a psychopath
yeah I'd be nice guy in real life I hope
but great if play a bad guy Norman son
sabatical honey he's able to get in your
head and also he's able to get in his
own head which is not normally a recipe
for good yeah when you start hearing
your own voice being projected that
makes me a little nervous they found
ways to make him unique and interesting
again it wasn't just here's Green Goblin
again like especially that shot with him
getting punched repeatedly and then like
just halfway through you just see him
grinning that might be the best shot in
like all three of the Tom Holland
Spider-Man
movies you're allowed to say Loki for
this one too Loki
I definitely watched the first season I
have to watched the second season I
heard was really good but it was
definitely one of the really really good
ones I loved it so much Miss Marvel show
one with uh kamla I think that was just
super fun and I feel it's a great energy
I think that MCU should use more I think
right now I got to go with moonnight
it's a great story it's great characters
it's it's it's great locations it needs
more hype I do like one division she's
cool honestly W division because like a
lot of the other shows they're still
good but sometimes they can feel like
just stretched out versions of like
Standalone movies and it played into the
strengths of TV as a format going way
back only Daredevil that is like the
only one I've I'll allow it and it's
coming back yeah he's pretty dope yeah I
mean he looks he looks good in the
sunglasses just like you do I know yeah
that's my inspiration and and both y'all
wear sunglasses at night holy sh we
might be the same person actually are
you a lawyer
maybe now you're talking like Loki yeah
that's it for today's on the street now
it's your turn comment and let us know
who's the strongest MCU hero who's your
favorite baddy and what's the best
Marvel TV show thanks for tuning and on
the street I'm Mark Ellis we'll see you
next time right here at Rotten Tomatoes
thanks for checking this vid out head
over to rotten tomatoes.com for
everything in the world of movies TV and
in between oh wait last
question no I think you're good he's the
best yes so are you thank you you too
all right we're here on the street with
Thomas right after that helicopter fly
is
over